being an architect is incredible it is
the dream job for so many people and to
be honest there is no better job out
there however it wasn't always the case
I've gone through hell and back to be
able to get to a position where I'm
truly happy and today I want to share my
top 10 tips for young architects around
the world including one incredible way
to double your salary in the early days
of your career so let's get started with
something that we're so used to
throughout University first of all we
need to get get some sleep stop pulling
all NS stop trying to impress everybody
and seriously just try and get some
sleep if your body isn't functioning
properly you're not going to be able to
perform your job at the highest quality
which means you're going to fall behind
and burn out very quickly so please get
some sleep make sure you eat healthy and
get some exercise into if you can to be
able to actually perform at your
absolute best the second mistake I see
so many young Architects do is starting
their own practice day one this is by
far the worst thing you can do because
you actually have no idea what you're
doing you may think that you've gone to
University you've learned all these
things you've got a master's degree in
architecture but let me be honest you
really have absolutely no idea as young
Architects we tend to have an ego as
well but what we don't realize is that
every architect that is worth their
title can actually design and most of us
coming fresh out of University think we
are the best at design think we know
absolutely everything the truth is you
know
nothing fourth of the list is you
genuinely have to stop trying to delay
your own success I see so many young
Architects coming into the Working World
and pushing themselves really hard doing
exceptionally well but what they aren't
doing is they're not completing their
log book They're not moving forward in
their career and they're not becoming
registered as actual Architects which
means they've spent the last decade if
not longer just trying to be in the
space but not actually being represented
in it that title alone sets you apart
from just a graduate to an actual
architect and as we know the word
architect is still a protected Title
Here in Australia it still comes with
its own challenges to acquire so that
means you have a certain level of
respect and understanding that you've
been able to acquire these skills and
this knowledge in order to be able to
call yourself an architect if you've
acquired that fantastic if you haven't
and even if you have the skills the
public around you doesn't know so stop
delaying it go get your registration and
be a proper architect next is the simple
fact that the grass is not greener on
the other side it is greener where you
water it and you have to water it to
become a great architect architecture is
a lifelong career it is something that
you will spend decades studying
practicing mastering and then eventually
passing your knowledge on down to the
Next Generation it is not something that
is picked up over a degree it is not
something that's picked up over few
projects it is a lifetime worth of
experience so you need to water the
grass in your own backyard you need to
keep fertilizing it you need to keep
maintaining it so that it will grow if
you just leave it alone it will be dead
it will not nurture it doesn't matter
how many times you move around I just
want to quickly jump in the middle of
this video and let you know that there
is an architectural checklist that you
can grab right now at
david.com.com drawings and everything
you may be forgetting to put in yours so
if you're just starting out and need a
little bit of assistance grab the
checklist go through it on every single
project and all of your drawings will
get significantly better and more
constructible if you can't grow by
yourself or you've hit a plateau in your
career it is time to find a mentor
mentors are hard to come by if you don't
have one in your own practice reach out
to other Architects that you may know
reach out to University lecturers reach
out to your friends architect reach out
to anybody that you know who might be
interested it might be as simple as
mentoring you over a cup of coffee
during your registration process it
could be as easy as simply giving them a
phone call for 20 minutes once a week it
doesn't have to be rigorous it doesn't
have to be formal but look for that
Mentor try and find somebody that has a
lot more knowledge than you and is
willing to teach you and share their
Journey with you you're stuck in the
office you're probably doing it wrong
and you haven't learned enough
architecture is all well and good and it
is great to be able to draw and design
and come up with Incredible ideas but if
it can't be built or if there's going to
be challenges on site you need to know
about them as a good architect so get
out on site learn what is actually being
constructed how it's being constructed
from what you've drawn if you're able to
get out on site you're going to be able
to actually just simply see so many more
opportunities that you could ever in a
textbook the weight of a brick is
significantly less than the weight of a
concrete beam or the weight of a nice
piece of Timber is significantly less
than the weight of a steel beam these
things you might not even consider and
until you get out on site and realize
this you may actually start to design in
different manners when you're actually
thinking about it from a
constructibility point of view and how
will we apply in the real world so get
out on site get active and go see as
many Builders as you possibly can to
learn as much as you can especially in
the early days something that I failed
to do in the early days of my career
which I'm making up for now is
networking networking is such a critical
part of the architectural experience
because first of all word of mouth is
where most of our clients will come from
so if you're active in the local
community if you're active in your
network they'll be able to drive some
business towards you but like I said
previously architecture is a lifelong
career it is something that you're going
to spend decades doing so building
quality strong relationships with good
people people and surrounding yourself
with these people for a prolonged period
of time will only ensure that you have a
successful career as time goes by second
last on our list is ask for more now
this principle is very simple if you've
been pigeon ho hold in your firm ask for
more if you're stuck doing renders ask
for something different if you're stuck
doing toilet layouts ask for something
different if you're not asking if you're
not speaking you won't get anywhere so
you actually need to figure out where
you want to go how you're going to get
there and then vocalize it if you go to
your boss your Superior whoever it is
that's defining Your Role at the moment
and go hey look I'm doing this right now
but I want to do this let me do it in my
own time if I have to so ask your boss
ask anybody just simply ask the last
piece of advice I have is the complete
opposite to what I've just said Ask less
now this might be a little bit confusing
considering what I've just said but ask
less applies to asking questions you're
going to be asking questions as your
career starts because you're not going
to know what's going on but if you're
asking the same questions Time and Time
and Time and Time Again people are going
to get extremely frustrated and learn
that you aren't learning you're not
paying attention and you're not taking
it seriously so take as many notes as
you possibly can take them in your
notepad on your computer on your phone
it doesn't matter where take notes once
you've taken the not not and ask the
question go back the next time you've
have the same question check all of your
notes and go okay here is the answer if
I've asked it before or if I know where
there to find the answer don't ask
anybody figure it out yourself by asking
less from your superiors you're going to
be able to show that you're independent
you're growing and you're able to excel
in your own space so ask more for the
right things ask less for the wrong
things now of course I promised one way
to easily double your salary in the
starting years now every architect that
comes in or every grad that comes in
pretty much comes in on the same level
playing field but what sets them apart
is their own unique skills that they've
learned completely outside of
architecture so for instance I had a
great photography and videography
business prior I brought that into my
architectural career and was able to
increase my salary I had an excellent
understanding of it and communication I
was able to bring that into my own
career and once again Excel further to
be able to bring these passions side
projects Hobbies whatever you want to
call them into your career provide
additional value so that you are less
replaceable is going to allow you to
increase your salary and also drive your
career forward rapidly anyway that's all
for me team thank you so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed my advice
over the years that I've collected and I
hope that you are successful in your
career if you enjoyed the video make
sure you smash that subscribe button
down below if you have any questions
leave them in the comments but like
always I'll see you next Monday